la première question qu'on s'était posée
c'était qui incarne aujourd'hui le mieux
la féerie et spontanément l'adie
miyazaki pour nous voilà c'est l'homme
qui aujourd'hui défini la féerie qui
pour moi vraiment la référence visuelle
que je voulais pour la belle et la bête
et puis bon c'est la technologie
d'aujourd'hui il ya toute une
un appareillage de petits trucs qu'on
s'approchera peut-être plus de princesse
mononoké d'une certaine manière du film
coteau
oui non les gens seront assez surpris je
crois devoir l'approchent j'ai beaucoup
cherché
qu'est ce que pouvait être ce château et
devaient le côté mise en tout cas
merveilleux du château en évitant
surtout un local américaine dans a
toujours cherché à garder cette espèce
de 2,2 d'énergie et d'un peu de folie
dans le style
chassons saint amand qui est fantasmée
et dans nos codes du conte de fées de
faire quelque chose qui soit pas trop
historiques et des visuels qui venaient
plus de la mode
essayez d'être modernisé poussins
les premières indications que j'ai donné
à mon chef opérateur c'est on va refaire
le technicolor anglais des années 40 qui
est plus puissant - crémeux - pictural
et plus organique mais qui à mon sens
reflète mieux justement les tourments
psychologiques des personnages et
notamment des personnages féminins
vous pouvez trouver une image qui soit
très original par rapport à ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui sur les écrans de
cinéma
umanis voulais faire quelque chose d'
européen mais quand même avec une
ampleur à puteaux américaine
utilisez une bougie pour vraiment
éclairé en saas très moderne
donc je dirai toujours mes films faut en
fait une espèce de transfert entre des
choses très moderne et puis des choses
très ancienne